One-hot encoding works very well from most problems until you
get into situations where you have tens of thousands, or
even millions of classes.
In that case, your vector becomes really, really large and
has mostly zeros everywhere and that becomes very inefficient.
You'll see later how we can deal with these problems using embeddings.
What's nice about this approach is that we can now measure how well we're doing
by simply comparing two vectors.
One that comes out of your classifiers and contains the probabilities of your
classes and the one-hot encoded vector that corresponds to your labels.
Let's see how we can do this in practice.
The natural way to measure the distance between those two probability vectors is
called the Cross Entropy.
I'll denote it by D here for distance.
Math, it looks like this.
Be careful, the cross entropy is not symmetric and
you have a nasty log in there.
So you have to make sure that your labels and
your distributions are in the right place.
Your labels, because they're one-hot encoded, will have a lot of
zeroes in them and you don't want to take the log of zeroes.
For your distribution, the softmax will always guarantee that you have a little
bit of probability going everywhere, so you never really take a log of zero.
So let's recap, because we have a lot of pieces already.
So we have an input, it's going to be turned into logits using a linear model,
which is basically your matrix multiply and a bias.
We're then going to feed the logits, which are scores,
into a softmax to turn them into probabilities.
And then we're going to compare those probabilities to the one-hot encoded
labels using the cross entropy function.
This entire setting is often called multinomial logistic classification.